we couldn't put this one off forever
could we love and monsters I know
because some of you guys have been
really upfront about the fact that you
were looking forward to me talking about
and most likely tearing in to what might
well be the most railed against single
episode of Doctor Who so where do we
begin
well unexpectedly I'm going to begin by
pointing out the merits of the thing so
here's the thing and it's not that I
didn't recognize this when I saw it
before the the episodes not exactly
subtle in terms of what it's doing but I
feel like I appreciated what it was
going for a little bit more because it
is ultimately it's a story about fandom
is what it is cuz you've got this group
who you know they they all have an
interest in the doctor that unites them
that's a commonality between them they
find other things they enjoy they find
other ways to you know have fun with
each other but then there enters a
different kind of fan one who basically
claims that they're doing fandom wrong
and they need to be doing it his way and
he takes control and when they you know
start to resist he absorbs them to make
them like himself
it turns this group of what had just
been fans into a group that is hunting
and hurting people and it is I'm not
sure if it was a term really being
bandied about at the time but it is a
story about toxic fandom and I don't
think it's completely coincidental that
the absorb all awful looks a bit like a
troll and I did double-check and the
term internet troll had already been in
use for quite a bit of time but then
when this thing aired so I can look at
that and go man I it's quite possible
that this is even more you know topical
now than it was at the time it was
originally made and now here's all the
reasons why it still doesn't friggin
work um so like I said I can recognize
what it was going for and I'll even give
it like a little bit of additional
credit in that it tries to make pretty
clear just how goofy this is gonna be
really early on because in the you know
even the cold open you know it seems
like it might just be Doctor Who
standard from a different characters
perspective but then you have the doctor
and rows and whatever the heck this
alien is I don't think we have a find
out what the name of the thing is
literally Scooby Doo chase each other
through a series of doors and it's
that's a pretty upfront thing of being
like this is a silly episode so you know
the thing tries but it doesn't work and
here's why not so first thing let's just
deal with the elf in the room the absorb
will off doesn't really work it doesn't
really work it kind of works as a
concept it doesn't fully come together
as a visual design and the performance
doesn't really work either I mean I feel
a little bit bad for the guy because
he's obviously trying to be a comedic
villain which is not an easy
to do to try for anyone to try and pull
off so you know I don't envy him that
job but and also I do I am also aware
that the original concept and rough
design of the thing was done by a child
as part of a concept contest
I am aware of that but that doesn't give
it a pass because it's the job of the
show the writers the makeup artists and
everything else to make that work and
they didn't so while I recognize that
that doesn't mean it gets a pass and
that's the other thing I rewatched this
and I recognized all the things that
it's saying about fandom all the things
that all the things that it is saying
about the way that a mutual love of
something can bring people together but
how that can also turn nasty and drive
people apart and become destructive
I can appreciate all that it's doing
there the problem is and this is a
problem that I I've had with more than a
few things over the years this is part
of the problem I have with the ending of
cabin in the woods you the analog the
metaphor the the allegory cannot be the
reason something works an allegory of
metaphor and analog whatever it may be
whatever point you know beyond the
immediate story that is being made can
enhance a story can make it deeper can
give it layers but it can't be the
reason it works the story has to still
work even if it wasn't an analog and it
wasn't an allegory and this doesn't what
little appreciation I have of it is only
there because I'm recognizing what it is
saying about fandom but if I take that
away and just look at it as a narrative
it's boring and it's silly and it's
stupid it's badly pasted
and that's that's kind of the end-all
be-all of the whole dang thing really
you know and and the guy who plays Elton
is fine you know the there's there's the
whole weird thing with the block of
concrete which also the joke the thing
ends on which like really a and the
thing just can't seem to fully decide on
a tone either because it's going is
being goofy yet at the same time
characters are dying and it tries to
have some emotional weight of the impact
of this this new figure on Linda
this one Linda with an eye not Linda
with the why I don't know if that was
intentional connection but I thought
that one did occur to me watching at
this time but I just it's trying to have
emotional stakes at the same time that
it's just being ridiculous and I'm not
saying a comedy can't have emotional
stakes or be emotionally impactful it
absolutely can but like something where
every element is this laughable where
the characters behave this ridiculously
or in the case of the Linda members this
stupidly like I don't care if you don't
know that he's an alien everything about
this guy is super suspicious oh no don't
go with your friends stay here just for
a little bit oh they haven't turned up
again oh goodness me you know the the
messages and the concepts about fandom
are not horrible ideas as a as a
launching pad they're not terrible ideas
as an underlying bit of theming but it's
just treated narrative ly so
ridiculously which i think is part of
why it doesn't feel like a celebration
of fandom it feels like
a mockery of fandom because it feels
like a mockery of an episode and so when
I say it's a mockery that's not
necessarily by intent that's by feel how
your left feeling is like this just
marked everything and it not in a way
that feels pleasant not in a way that
feels loving it's not I wouldn't go so
far as to call it mean-spirited but it's
it just isn't finding the value in the
ridiculousness that it's that it's
laying out and I don't particularly like
what it does with Jackie I don't think
because it would have been one thing if
this was like new information you know
the fact that she is this kind of lonely
and that she has this gravitation
towards men but we knew that we knew
that from literally Episode one of the
new era of Doctor Who and when she saw
Eccleston he's like oh you know you're
here anything could happen
the doctor you guys know and walks away
like we knew so we knew immediately so
this is not new information and dwelling
on it with Elton it just it just feels
kind of mean it's like we're wallowing
in somebody's sadness like the the whole
thing it's just totally and thematically
at odds between what it's trying to do
and the feel it wants to have yet the
way it's approaching all this stuff the
thing is just a mess
top to bottom and yet at the same time
underneath all the elements that don't
work which is almost all of them the
monster doesn't work the dynamic between
the characters is okay ish the narrative
device of Elton talking to the camera
doesn't really add anything the threat
is goofy and yet people are dying you
know that all of all these problems are
all layered over the initial starting
kernel of the theming of talking about
fandom and how it can be a wonderful
thing or it can be an awful thing
and that again had potential like going
back and watching it this time I
couldn't even see how every how if it
was actually a good episode these themes
could have made a good episode great but
because it's not a good episode instead
it just makes a bad episode pretentious
so that's love and monsters I I don't
know if people were expecting an angry
rant out of me and this I think some
folks were but I'm just mostly
bewildered by the thing and I'm more
frustrated than angry like if I hadn't
found anything of value if I hadn't
found this sort of nugget of the
underlying themes and appreciated the
more because like I said it's not like I
didn't realize it was about fandom but
like I didn't really exam I because I
hadn't revisited the episode I didn't go
back and really examine the ways in
which that all plays out and there's
some real potential in that idea and it
just makes me frustrated as opposed to
angry so love and monsters what are your
thoughts on it whatever they are drop
something down in the comments
well that's talked about a whole bunch
of stuff we can do because there's
buttons and links and all sorts of stuff
down below there is a peel box there's
merch you know check it out if you feel
like it there's my patreon but you know
what if you don't want to look at any of
that or any of the other links that are
available down there that is okay
because at the end of the day you are
the council
I'm just running the meetings and until
next time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]